hey guys I just wanted to make one more
video to update you guys I got my NG
tube out my IV was detached in the
surgery was a complete success I'll have
a few more scars but as far as I know
there'll be no other complications with
anything and I most likely will be able
to go home either today or tomorrow I'll
still be recovering for a little bit
longer but once again I just wanted to
say thank you guys so much for all the
kind words you said while I was sick in
the hospital and the fact that you guys
got and not just you but other youtubers
poured love from the community it means
you know it's hard to find the words to
show how much that means to be in the
know that people care that much so just
thank you guys so much I can't wait to
get back to making videos again but I
know that people are probably shouting
at me to get rest and I will I promise
you I will get rest and I will get
better and I will feel better and I feel
better already because I spent so much
time reading your messages I still will
so thank you everybody so much for
caring and thank you both so much for
watching these videos and as always I'll
see you in the next one bye bye